An IDS typically uses these approaches
to analyze data and detect intrusions.
Anomaly detection, by definition,
it tries to detect what is not normal.
Misuse or signature detection, you
try to find a match of no intrusions.
There are mainly two elements
in anomaly detection.
The first is training or profiling.
The goal is to define or characterize
the normal or expected behavior.
This is accomplished by collecting
data linking to normal activities, and
applying data analysis
algorithm to construct a model.
The second,
is to evaluate whether an observed
behavior fits the normal profile.
This is accomplished by
analyzing the observed data
to see whether it fits
the established model.
Misuse or signature detection,
involves first encoding normal
text into patterns or rules,
and then comparing the current
behavior with these rules or patterns.
To see whether there's a match or not.
Obviously, this approach can only detect
known intrusions or known attacks.